Imagine a world
where everything you see is filtered.
Designed
specifically to your unique preferences.
evolving intuitively to your desires
before they even form in your own mind.
Or a world where you can be anywhere.
Anyone, without leaving your bedroom.
But what if this world...
...sucks?
Are we going to be able to live
without these devices?
How is this going to change
how we experience space?
And how will these virtual dimensions
affect our physical world?
A portion of this video
sponsored by Wayfair.
Virtual reality
is the promise of a fully immersive,
interconnected universe
that transcends physical limitations.
a world unbound by gravity,
material limitations or cost.
Sounds kind of like the dream, right?
Augmented reality is even more interesting
because it can enhance our physical
world by overlaying digital information
and objects on top of our real world.
Both of these could completely transform
all areas of life,
including how we use our environments.
Now we can all be in the same space,
but have a completely subjective
experience of that space.
But why does all of this
still feel so far from reality?
Public transit
is this unique in-between space
where we can physically exist
in a communal space, but mentally be
immersed in our personal worlds.
It's also a universal experience,
So it's kind of the best way
to observe cultural changes
But there's something about this image
that's a little bit unsettling,
and it might have something
to do with ambiguity.
According to Claude Lévi-Strauss,
The facial disguise temporarily
eliminated from social intercourse.
The part of the body which reveals
personal feelings and attitudes.
The reason why masks can be creepy,
even if it's neutral or happy,
might have something to do
with the fact that it hides the emotions
or intentions of the person underneath.
I don't know if this person is crying
or glaring at me,
And this weird psychological phenomenon
might be why Apple
spent millions of dollars
developing this feature called Eyesight,
which at first
seems like a completely useless feature.
It basically allows people
to see an actual life simulation
of your eyes with data
from the internal infrared cameras
two per eye, to capture your eye movement
and facial expressions.
The data is then fed to a machine
learning algorithm that combines it
with your own unique digital persona
using the front facing truedepth camera.
all of this tech in R&D,
just so that you can see
if somebody is looking directly at you
or if they're immersed in their VR space.
And this connection between
what's happening behind your glasses
and your surroundings could be
one of the key steps to massive option.
and as we get more comfortable
wearing these devices, it's
going to unlock a whole new world
that straddles between the physical
and the digital.
Historically architecture
used programing diagrams
to define distinct separate spaces.
As we get into more postmodern
architecture, we start to get a bleeding
of different programs
creating these in-between spaces.
VR and the air allow us to merge
all of this
and create multiple spaces
within one physical space.
And not just that each person
could have a totally different experience
of that space.
Basically, everything we know about three
dimensional space goes out the door
and we get what Matsuda calls
the subjective space, where
everyone can be in the same environment
and experience different realities.
Someone sitting
just next to you on the bus will see
a completely different city curated
to their personal taste and interests.
You can be in your digital bedroom
while you're physically in a cubicle
or an airplane or a prison cell.
you can also be in a museum
or a concert hall or an aquarium
or a basketball court
or a pool or a school or a library
There's something fundamentally human
about wanting to share a communal,
physical experience with other people.
studies have found that going
through a shared experience
just by being in the same space
can intensify that experience,
even if there's no verbal exchange
and even if it's just with strangers.
In this one study from Yale University,
students were given chocolates
either simultaneously
with another participant or alone.
Despite both chocolates being identical.
Students
reported the chocolates tasting better
when the ADA
with the other person in the room.
And that's why even if we don't need
to, we like going to a library
or a coffee shop.
We like being in the same space
in the presence of other people.
These are some of the moments from
the Lightship Summit conference in 2022.
The graphics are still kind of
at a rudimentary level,
but it's an example of how virtual content
can mesh with the physical world.
The goal was to create a local experience
that could only exist
in this specific location.
And in order to do this, the overlay
the virtual space
on top of the existing space
using traditional architectural techniques
like plans, sections, 3D modeling,
as well as new VR tools to draw
these cute little elements that interact
with the people and the space.
and the result is a spatial experience
where the digital fabric
is woven into the architecture
of this conference venue.
most of this is experienced
through the phone like this.
But once headsets
become a part of our daily routines,
we're going to have a much more seamless,
immersive experience.
So I think rather than subjective space,
maybe brick and mortar stores
are going to try to capitalize on this
innate desire to be in the same space
and try to create a hyper local experience
that can only be experienced
at their stores.
we've seen how stores have transformed
since the rise of Instagram
with more and more of these themed stores
popping up.
Maybe we'll be seeing
an amplified version of this
where stores combine air
and their physical space to create
a unique experience
that you can't replicate anywhere else.
What does this are?
It's time to talk about Wayfair.
You probably know of Wayfair as a website
where you can buy affordable
and chic furniture.
But did you know that they also have
an educational YouTube channel?
a style is born as their new series,
where they discuss how and why
certain styles came to be.
It's really well-produced,
really well-researched,
and I love how they break down the history
of that style
from the social and economic conditions
and why it's making a comeback.
and I think when you understand
the context behind something,
you can really appreciate it a lot more
beyond just the esthetics of it.
Anyways, I would highly recommend
you check out their episode
on how Brutalism influenced interior
design.
I personally love Brutalism,
but it's also quite controversial.
People either love it or hate it.
But what's certain is that it's spread
all over the world
and became a trend in itself.
so yeah, check it out
and go and subscribe to their channel.
I'll include the link in the description.
But what happens when
we leave the public realm
and into our homes?
The design of homes can be
one of the best ways
to observe the changes in culture
or lifestyle.
You went from this to this to this.
As a TV went from this to this to this.
In fact, TV has been the focal point
of our living rooms for decades.
We orient things around the TV
because it's not just entertainment.
As weird as it is.
It's kind of a passive bonding experience.
But what if and this is a huge
what if TVs become obsolete?
imagine your homes without TV's.
Everyone plugs
into their own entertainment.
Or if you want to have a shared
viewing experience, plug into a device
that syncs all of your movies.
We might lay things out
specifically for talking or hanging out.
Maybe we can bring back conversation bits
which could even be covered
when it's not being used, giving
you even more space for VR activities.
But since this requires more floor space,
we can get a rise in modular furniture
that could be arranged in multiple ways.
Maybe we'll start getting more of this,
then this Or we could start
to adopt more movable or sliding walls
to adjust the space for VR use.
Keiichi Matsuda
predicts that there's
going to be two factions of designers, one
that deals with the physical layer
and the other on the digital.
And since digital design
can be much more cost effective
and resource efficient and that in
constructing physical structures,
we can potentially create safer,
more accessible
and more statically pleasing spaces
with the same budget.
This could even prioritize initiatives
for street beautification,
which often ranks very low in budgetary
considerations.
Lower income communities
could get the same kind
of esthetic treatment as wealthier
neighborhoods, maybe more green spaces,
more architectural diversity, or streets
lined with trees.
But what about this experience?
Being in nature
has a whole lot of health benefits.
And one of the reasons is because it's
a very holistic multi sensory experience.
In fact, tactile stimulation
has been linked to improvements in memory
and learning, spatial awareness,
and even emotional connection.
But most of our current world is created
considering only
one of the five senses sight.
Yoani Plasma
is the author of Eyes of the Skin,
also one of my favorite books.
And he writes, The suppression
of other sensory
realms has led to an impoverishment
of our environment,
causing a feeling of detachment
and alienation.
These intangible elements are very easily
neglected,
especially in the face of rapid change.
But these are the things they can enrich.
Our experiences.
It's hard for me
to not imagine a dystopian future
where trees just look like trees, but
don't smell or sound or move like them.
Or you step into a cabin,
but you don't smell the cedar.
You can't feel the grains of wood
or the concrete on your skin.
Maybe we won't even notice what's missing
because we forgot what it feels like.
Or these real tactile experiences
are reserved only for certain people
or certain neighborhoods
But what if, instead of creating
completely new environments, it's
more about filling in the gaps?
I'd imagine that
filling in a tree
between two existing trees would require
a lot less computational power
than creating it from scratch.
But it could also increase
the believability of virtual objects
by sitting between the real objects.
Our brains
also have a tendency to fill in the gaps,
so it could read the virtual elements
as real.
It could even apply
to architectural details.
One of the mandates of modernism,
which was a reaction
to the Beaux Arts
Movement, was to democratize architecture
by stripping it of all of its ornaments
because ornamentation was expensive.
But let's be honest,
maybe other than architects,
I think most people would pick this over
this.
With air, we could bring back
delicate ornamentation.
Maybe it could even change
how we tell certain elements
to be better equipped for air.
This idea of filling in the gaps,
it could even happen at the macro level,
at the city scale.
In typical city grids,
we have our front streets
and our back alleys,
which are usually the leftover space.
Designers
have attempted to design the back alleys
with not a huge amount of success,
but with the help of air.
Maybe we can actually design and program
the alleys
or parking lots with very little cost,
and we can actually start
to use these leftover spaces.
The digital divide suggests
that with these new technologies,
we're going to see an even bigger gap
between the rich and poor.
those who can afford to will have access
to more information
and also a better spatial experience
where the wealthy can buy spaces
with less ads and they're going to have
a more comfortable
and accessible air space.
But maybe with the right guidance
and strategic implementation,
we could actually close that gap
and we could use virtual content
to increase the esthetic standards
and create environments that are beautiful
and inclusive and engaging
and layered all at the same time.
right
now, a very select few in society shape
our environments
just due to the sheer
amount of training involved.
But in the digital world,
where rigorous standards like building
codes don't have to apply, it
opens the doors for more people
from all backgrounds to influence
the visual fabric of our communities.
But who knows?
Maybe our virtual experiences
will be so cool
that we forget about our physical world
altogether.
What do you guys
think about all these dimensions?
Let me know in the comments.
Also, we have a Discord community
and a newsletter.
I'll leave the links in the description.
And with that,
I'll see you in the next video.
over here.
whoa, whoa.
Oh, model.
I Is that illusory, sarcastic.
So you have got to frame baby.
Now I make a move
like a child to
As a TV
went from this to this to this.